pour vous c'est quoi le local alors pour
moi le localisme c'est le patriotisme de
la reconstruction c'est faire primer le
local mais par que dans la nourriture
c'est faire du circuit court une sorte
de doctrine et surtout en fait une arme
pour jouer collectif
à l'échelle d'un territoire c'est faire
de la proximité un critère qu'ils soient
pris en compte mais au même titre que le
prix nous nous croyons en la république
des territoires et donc les territoires
force et une république forte
une idée pour relancer notre pays alors
aujourd'hui
en fait tout est quasiment voire
exclusivement orientée sur le critère
prix et on voit les limites du système
nos tpe le poème ea elles ont besoin
d'un avantage concurrentiel
en fait ce même avantage il doit pouvoir
aussi servir et aider les entreprises à
haute valeur sociale et environnementale
et donc il nous faut là où il faut
utiliser la force de frappe de la
puissance publique
qu'est qui est un vrai outil de relance
et nous avons les moyens d'impulser une
vraie orientation donner de l'oxygène à
noter que hello nos pme qui maillent le
territoire avec une clause locale qui
serait une nouvelle clé qui permettra et
bien d'accompagner de choisir nos tpe et
aux pme
et oui d'assumer le mot mais leur
permettent de rivaliser avec les plus
grosses entreprises une plus grande
force de frappe
finalement le circuit court il a trop
été trop longtemps contenue aubry
dentaire là ça deviendrait une doctrine
un outil comme député quel levier
alors eh bien des garde-fous sont
nécessaires
tous d'accord mais je pense que nous
devons permettre cette liberté de jouer
territorialement doit y est encore plus
forte
la république des territoires si notre
conception de l'organisation du pays
alors j'ai envie de dire faisons faire
une révolution au code des marchés
publics et créons absolument une cause
locale une clause sociale
[Musique]